wie gesund es milch welche risiken haben
die tabletten die mein arzt mehr gegeben
hat welche maske schütz foto vitt 19
welche hantel übung ist die beste für
starke bizeps wer weiß so was klar das
smartphone kann das netz uns helfen
gesünder zu leben
zunächst es ja mal festzustellen dass
der freie zugang zu freien informationen
insbesondere zur gesundheits
informationen zu begrüßen ist sich mit
informationen auszustatten sich neuem
wissen zuzuwenden bleibt am ende immer
ein wagnis in allen lebens kontexten er
mit hilfe einer großen suchmaschine
gewicht abbauen möchte findet alleine
auf englisch rund 100 millionen
ergebnisse und wer pickel loswerden
möchte bekommt bei youtube tausende
tipps hier kommt es eben darauf an genau
einschätzen zu können woher kommt der
content wie wissenschaftlich fundiert im
falle von medizinischen informationen
ist ein solcher inhalt und letztlich
liegt das dann wieder auch in der
verantwortung des einzelnen die private
bertelsmann stiftung in deutschland hat
über 1000 personen befragt wie sie bei
der suche nach gesundheitsinformationen
im internet vorgehen
ergebnis viele gehen davon aus dass die
treffer nach relevanz oder gar
aktualität sortiert sind und schauen
sich nur die ersten ergebnisse an
wir sehen in den top3 einer suchmaschine
meistens die inhalte die eine hohe
reputation genießen damit aber nicht
automatisch wahr sind trotzdem können
suchmaschinen natürlich nützlich sein
sie sind das tor zur welt der
gesundheitsinformation für viele denn
ohne suchmaschinen wären dann auch die
guten informationen schwer auffindbar
doch wie geht man vor wenn man
verlässliche informationen im netz
finden will
ziehe ich eine internetseite mit mir
gefälligen gesundheitsinformationen
zurate sollte ich über das impressum
hinaus schauen mit wem habe ich es
eigentlich zu tun
wer ist der herausgeber der information
und welche motive leiten ihnen
gesundheitsinformationen ins netz zu
stellen
eine anlaufstelle für gute
gesundheitsinformationen sind patient
verbände die sich vielleicht im umfeld
einer bestimmten krankheit bewegen oder
sich eben auch wissenschaftlichen
quellen bedienen
wer krank ist kann den social media oder
speziellen foren erfahrungen mit anderen
austauschen
es gibt nützliche tipps aber auch hier
ist skepsis angebracht gespräch in
social media über gesundheitsfragen
führen wir dort schriftlich die schrift
verleitet schnell zu der annahme diese
informationen konnten eine besondere
güter an eine besondere qualität eine
besonders starke aussagekraft haben aber
wir müssen uns klar machen dass das
nicht der fall ist
alleine auf instagram erscheinen jeden
tag viele millionen neue fotos dass es
sich dabei nicht immer um seriöse
informationen handeln kann liegt
eigentlich auf der hand
wachsamkeit ist sicherlich einer der
zentralen ratschläge im umgang mit
gesundheitsinformationen vor allen
dingen dann wenn ich sie online erhalten
habe aber selbst auch dann wenn ich sie
aus expertenhand entgegengenommen habe
erst das zusammenspiel im kontext was
hat diese information konkret mit mir zu
tun gibt es noch zweite oder dritte
meinungen gibt es noch weitere quellen
mit denen ich mich auseinandersetzen
kann macht uns gesundheitskompetenz und
hier unsere wichtigsten tipps von wem
stammt die information welche ziele
verfolgt sie auf welche quellen stützt
sich die aussage gibt es studien wie alt
ist die information wird sie regelmäßig
aktualisiert